[Music]
Tsukasa-chan, you're leaving already. No, I'm
thinking about taking a sauna. If your
husband wants to join too, please go.
[Music] If you don't like it, don't go in
from the beginning. If you don't
like it, start from the beginning. If you don't
like it, then this is like a girls' manga.
Scene: This is something I have to go to. I
took a bath with my wife, and I also
took a sauna together. It's all for the sake of world peace. By the way, Kaname-chan
's sauna is
set at a very high temperature.  What's this?
With this,
I can only do so many things in 5 minutes. Can I maintain my naughty feelings in this heat wave,
or rather, my love for my wife?
[Music] My
husband has also come. I feel like I have
plenty of time
next to me.  Of course, the
sauna here is quite hot,
isn't it?
Tsukasa-chan, how long can you go in the sauna?Of
course, to the limit.Sauna is a
battle with yourself, husband.What do you mean by
yourself in this overwhelming amount of heat?
Everyone, I see. It's not what I
thought. Tsukasa-chan
likes saunas,
right? No, that's not true. It's not me, but humanity who
likes saunas.
Two men and women, almost completely naked, in a closed room.
Even though it's a sauna, it doesn't feel naughty.I feel like it's wrong to
do something naughty in a sauna room, but it's still
human beings who take on the challenge.What are you
doing, Tsukasa-chan?
Add water and steam.  I
feel like there isn't enough of a challenge, and I
don't need that kind of challenge.